but once you did Conan you did pilot
first
uh no I mean he had the job right you
know and then and then it's sort of like
you do
I started in June I think and the show
aired in September so we had a pretty
you know good long time to ramp up and
get stuff
uh pre you know pre-tapes done and get
some you know comedy written up and then
um
uh we had I think we did about 10 Test
shows what'd you do right after that uh
I came out here and I I got a a deal to
do a a sitcom called Andy Richter
controls the Universe on Fox and a guy
named Victor Fresco uh he created it I
kind of you know in talks with me
um and and he I met with a bunch of
people I was gonna do a sitcom I knew
you know I knew the way it worked that
when you came from when you were off the
market for a while and you were on
something legit that you're all of a
sudden like I would see it so much with
people like Rob cordray or Matt Walsh
who were on the on the uh the uh The
Daily Show yeah they were correspondents
on The Daily Show then leaving The Daily
Show and then it's like here's you know
just deals getting thrown at them yeah
you know we love them so I knew uh oh
Matt's yeah he's he's yeah he's done
this
he's another one that is of we did
improv back together back in Jesus what
a great guy he's so talented just the
best yeah we just text each other filth
uh like he just does he talk does he
talk to you about bread too like yeast
no no no he just texted me he loves you
something like hey you stupid I'm I'm
picketing at Disney and telling everyone
you're on the producer's side where the
[__] are you
and I and I texted him back I said you
know I got four ribs removed this
weekend to facilitate better
self-sucking videos
I'm in no shape to chance yeah so that's
our we text each other we came up with
that whole is that a myth that people
did get their ribs removed well
supposedly Salvador Dali did it and
supposedly Marilyn Manson I remember the
Marilyn Manson yeah yeah but is it was
it just like an urban legend I don't
know
I just I I'd like to get to the root of
this I don't even know what the [__]
you're talking about I mean is this
something that you would do is like if
you could chuck bottom ribs removed and
supposedly you can then you know get
like get the flip your legs over your
head and suck your own dick I'd have to
get four removed
[Laughter]
you need an extra vertebrae to kind of
because you need more oh that's true too
you need to add you advert about it like
from a snake yes yes yes yeah maybe you
know from an oxtail oxtail yeah you can
buy the whole rack at Costco yeah yeah
oh yeah like osso buco yeah
so you just bring oxtail to the to the
Dolphins right right yeah I want this
replaced put in whichever one yeah yeah
it's up to you yeah um you could to suck
your own dick yeah I don't want to suck
my own dick I've never had that fantasy
I don't think I yeah yeah yeah I mean
well the taste would be okay I think
yeah I mean come on you've tasted your
own [__]
[Laughter]
yeah of course once a long yeah yeah
once or twice maybe but it was a long
time again I can't nine times
you know the number every time yeah
diary yeah yeah it happened again this
is the last time
you think you can make yourself come
though what do you mean with your mouth
I don't know I mean it doesn't hurt it's
up to you no not the [__] part okay
that's the sucking part I'm gentle with
the sucking part of annoying no it's
annoying her you know it's the it's the
Ben yeah the bending yeah yeah you got
extra six oxtail implanted yeah I think
I would have to get Triple locks What's
that I don't know no one could walk you
yeah
because you can't once that once you get
caught doing that it's over but also in
Showbiz term that's a retirement plan
when everything else goes goes south you
are the guy that can suck his own dick
and you work you don't stop work
you're only fans account
yeah I wanted to start an only fans
account called only hams where I get I
enter a feeder relationship like a
feederism relationship what's a
feudalism well it's basically like you
and me for instance right like I'm 135
pounds now but my goal is to like 500
pounds and so you basically just feed me